hello everyone and welcome to the first
match we'll be covering from the
chestable Masters Division One winners
uh winner bracket uh it's
vladislavartame versus Magnus Carlson
and this is the Armageddon game uh the
first four games they played which are
of Rapid time format 15 minutes per
player and three seconds increment uh
every player one with the white pieces
which also means that every no sorry
every player one with the black pieces
which also means every player lost with
the white pieces and the first Artemis
took to win the magnets retaliated then
our team won game three and the Magnus
again equalized in game four and this is
now uh game five and uh here they don't
just okay they play Armageddon but it's
not um you know the time format is not
set in stone they have to bid for their
time so you start with 15 minutes but
you can offer to start with less which
is I think it's it's an incredibly uh
efficient system and really awesome uh
you know you get to see how low is
someone willing to go to get the black
pieces because everyone wants to play
with black because you only need need a
draw to win the match so uh Magnus bid 7
minutes and 58 seconds it's much much
less than for example Hikaru Hikaru I
think bid nine minutes and something and
in the other uh armageddon's also nine
minutes and something was built but
Magnus went as low as 7 minutes and 58
seconds that's almost half the time that
you start with as you you should start
with 15 minutes so he did get the black
pieces but he now has very little time
on the clock so can he just force a draw
okay maybe he can also win but uh what
he cannot allow is for Artemis to win
because if he does he wins the match
it's not all lost if you lose because
this is the Winner's bracket and even if
you fall down to the losers bracket you
can still win the tournament it's uh
sort of like if you remember when we
were discussing the 1958 to 1959 uh us
Chess Championship uh Bobby Fischer
declines the play because he said that
uh he he didn't feel a single round
robin was enough to actually see who who
is the strongest he knew that he would
win but he said okay maybe he can lose a
game and then maybe someone could have a
tournament of his life and all of a
sudden yeah you don't win and then you
don't qualify for the interzoneal and so
on and so on which we all know how it
ended uh so uh they didn't um I want to
introduce a a double round robin system
and so Bobby didn't play but here even
if you lose one match you can still
bounce back and win the entire event so
uh you know it's not all lost if you
lose one game but okay that being said
let's check it out Magnus uh has uh uh 7
minutes and 58 seconds and I'll tell me
of the full 15 minutes let's see how it
goes our team opens with E4 we have C5
by Magnus he goes for the Sicilian
Defense and now G3
attack uh avoiding uh pretty much all
the main lines he doesn't want the
magnets to have an easy way of
equalizing and just getting a draw even
though this is basically equalizing
right now but uh you know at least
you're sure that Magnus can't force a
draw here so G6 by Magnus with Bishop to
G2 and now Bishop to G7 we have Knight
to E2 and now Knight to C6 so just
nicely developing Magnus with full
control over the D4 Square we have
castles and now Pawn to D6 and Here pawn
to D3 so not having the open zillion uh
Artemis wants to slow play this as much
as possible with E5 by Magnus and not
Knight beat the C3 we have Knight G2 E7
Ponte F4 now and Magnus castles with
Bishop to E3 and now Bishop D6 football
player just nicely developing pieces
with Queen to D2 now uh preparing to a
if if at some point the position opens
up you can always trade off the dark
Square version herbs and Magnus was
ignite the D4 it's a beautiful Square
for the Knight and Magnus plans on
keeping it there as long as possible so
Rook F2 Artemis now wants to double up
on the f file before deciding on where
to capture or push Queen to D7 Magnus
now saying that he's also ready to trade
off the light Square Bishops with Bishop
to H3 and Rook a to F1 so nicely
doubling up nothing out of the ordinary
happening here and the position has been
reached before some no moves are Pawn to
F6 Pawn to F5 Rook 8 to C8 uh even King
to h8 but here Magnus went for the
immediate Bishop to H3 and it is now as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game so Artemis trades with Bishop
captures Queen captures and now he plays
F captures on E5 now why did he trade a
trade off so quickly well he has a very
concrete plan captures and Bishop to G5
he wants to win the D5 Square for his
Knight and you know from experience when
playing against the ceil in if you if
you plan the Knight on D5 you will have
a great game so here Rook 888 and
Artemis just trades uh trades the bishop
for Knight so Bishop captures through
captures and Knight the D5 and this is
now a monster knight uh it's um very
hard to get rid of it because it's on a
light Square Magnus is a dark Square
Bishop so at some point Magnus will have
to re-maneuver his Knight in order to
maybe trade it for this Knight so he
plays a rook to D7 and now Pawn to C3 uh
chasing away the Knight you could also
consider just Knight captures on D4
because then you know that your knight
is staying on D5 forever but you allow C
captures on D4 then the C2 Pawn becomes
weak then uh you know you you can uh
double Rooks and on the C file okay you
can't touch the C7 square but you can
put the Rook on C6 and C8 and have a
very nasty pressure on that C2 Pawn so
it would definitely be a trade-off but
uh C3 Artemis decides against this uh
Knight to E6 and now King the H1 uh we
have Knights to C7 now offering a trade
of Knight and here uh Magnus should
probably have just played C4 uh one
thing it does it prevents artemy from
playing C4 uh which really cements that
Knight on D5 and other thing
um it's very very very unpleasant uh how
for example if you capture there's Queen
G4 and now your E4 Pawn is extremely
weak but okay he went Knight to the C7
he offered the trade Knights and now
just Pawn the C4 now if Magnus trades
then artemi would get a very very strong
pass Ponce capture D5 and this would be
hard to deal with so Queen back to E6
and now Knight eat the C3 with Pawn to
F6 by Magnus and now Queen to E2 uh
Knight to A6 now uh we're trying to
re-maneuver the Knight over to the D4
Square you want to win I'd be eight
Knight to C6 and then Knight to D4 we
have A3 taking away the B4 square but
still Knight to B8 uh we have Queen to
E3 putting pressure on the C5 pawn and
B6 by Magnus we have Pawn to B4 as soon
as Pawn to B4 becomes possible you
should always play it and our team even
knows this so upon the B4 captures
captures and now I Knights the C6 going
after that D4 Square Knight the E tuna
Artemis stops this and now Queen to D6
putting pressure on the B4 pawns upon
the B5 and now Knight the d8 now the
Knight is being re-maneuvered to E6 and
then maybe later on to D4 or F4 maybe in
some lines maybe G5 all depends on what
Artemis comes up with and he starts with
H4 now you can't just wait it's a fine
position yes you have a uh B Pawn B5 and
Magnus has a backward spawn on A7 so
this is all very nice for you uh but you
also have to win the game and uh you
know there is no increment here so if
you if you get low on time uh it's not
going to be easy so Knights the E6 by
Magnus and Ponte H5 now we have Rook D
to F7 Magnus doubles up on the f file
and now Knight to G1
now here H6 was uh definitely playable
and now if Bishop to h8 then G4 stops
spawn to F5 by black but even though
this is uh this is looking great it's a
very hard to figure out how to actually
break through here so it's uh you know a
fine position but maybe not playable in
Armageddon so Knights the G1 artemi
wants to bring the Knight closer to the
black king we have Pawn to F5 as now he
allowed it he didn't play G4 H6 and not
Magnus throws in F4 and this is not a
problem for our team if G captures on F4
Bishop captures an H6 now pins the F
Pawn Queen to H3 and now Bishop captures
on F4 and it seems like uh Magnus really
stabilized this position it's very hard
to see how Artemis could even break
through but it's Armageddon and Magnus
is also getting very low on time so here
we have Knight to F3 King to G7 uh we
have rooked the G2 and now Knight to C5
here Magnum said the very interesting
move Bishop to C1 because for playing
Knight to the C1
a knight to C5 and now it's very hard to
see what do you would you actually play
here you don't you never allowed this
Knight to take the bishop with Tempo and
you're gonna play Knight to C5 on the
next move let's say you play Rook to G1
still Knight the C5 and you can never
capture this because the uh the Knight
on F3 would hang and now the D3 Pawn is
hanging and it's just not not very
pleasant uh so uh definitely in the
position but the magnets went Knight to
the C5 right away and now comes Knight
to H4 now the Knight can come to F5 and
could be a bit annoying uh as the the
g-pawn is pinned so here Queen to E6 not
allowing this nasty pin to happen and
now Rook to G4 as your queen is being
threatened here so Rook to G4 and now
Magnus has to figure out a way how to
play this now remember the Rook cannot
move uh so that's uh that's a pretty big
thing but one thing you don't want to
have is the pressure of this knight ever
delivering a check so you might as well
just play King to G8 and then the game
continues if Rook after G1 you can even
play Bishop G5 and you can never capture
because just Queen captures Queen so
let's say Knight to F5 uh now you just
play Rook captures on F5 e captures Rook
captures and it's uh very very tricky
position uh White maybe a slightly
better but nothing uh
uh black can hold you you can never
capture on G5 because if you capture
just The Rook captures and if Queen
captures any sticks with check Knight
recaptures and now of course if you
capture the Knight is defending the G5
Pawn you do not want to play the same
game so you're gonna have to play some
like Rook day one but still it's not not
going to be much more than a draw
however Magnus didn't go for this and
it's not the only move you can play some
other moves like Rook to F6 also a
viable plan but Magnus played Knight
captures on D3 and you know it seems
like a reasonable idea because if you
capture then Queen captures on G4 but
there is one very nasty idea that Magnus
missed in this position so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
Artemis uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
very nasty idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures and G6 with check this is what
Magnus missed and it's sort of a you
know called the police but not for me
moment it seems like the Rook cannot
move because the queen hangs when in
fact that's not uh you know the the
reality at all uh so now if you capture
back with the pawn for example then just
Queen captors Queen and you've blundered
the full Queen so Magnus has to play
Queen captures in G6 now comes Knight
captures on G6 H captors and now Queen
captures on D3 and if you count
everything uh Magnus now has a rook for
a queen but okay Artemis also getting
very very long clock and that black
white king is stuck in the corner maybe
it's possible for the Rooks to somehow
Checkmate the white king and that's what
Magnus is going for Rook Dayja to check
King to G1 and now Rook the H5 with
Knight captures and F4 uh vladislav just
wants to eliminate as many attackers as
possible and not falling for some sort
of Checkmate he captures an F4 and now
Queen to D4 check and this is a
beautiful centralizing move by Tammy as
you'll see later on King H6 now Ponte E5
now Artemis is ready to start pushing
his Pawn to become a queen F3 by Magnus
we have E6 and now Rook to G5 with check
uh the problem uh with a move like uh uh
like Rook to H7 for example is that the
queen from D4 covers the G7 square and
you will never be able to put the King
on G7 in order to try some sort of a
checkmating attack so instead Magnus
wins Rook to G5 with check King to H2
and now Rook the G2 with check again
this looks uh spectacular if you could
just move the king you might even
Checkmate the white king but the queen
covers the G7 Square so that's not
happening that's why the queen on D4 is
so spectacularly placed so look the G2
check by Magnus King to H3 and now you
really have nothing more to try
uh Magnus played because Rook captures
and F3 is coming then The Rook will hang
so Magnus played Rook to H7 it was a
last attempt at saving the game if maybe
somehow our team if doesn't play real
captors on F3 then it could be very
tricky if you if you're allowed to this
check but of course the vladislav played
it will captures an F3 Rook to G5 Now by
Magnus and just Pawn to E7 this is again
impossible it's just you know I'm sure
Magnus was furious at not being able to
go into G7 uh Rook captures on E7 but
now uh he gives up the h8 square so
Queen to h8 with check Rook to H7 and
now the king hunt begins or queen to f8
with tracking to H5 and Rook F4
threatening mate in one so Rook to F5
you have to play this now Rook H4 check
King G5 Queen to d8 check Rook to F6 and
now just to Rook captures on H7 of
course Magnus can resign this but um I
think uh Artemis had like 10 seconds on
the clock and Magnum said also like 10
seconds on the clock so it's possible to
flag your opponent uh you know not a
very honorable way to win but no one has
honor you know on this level you want to
win at any cost so King the F5 and now
Queen to D5 with check King to F4 and
now Rook the H4 with check we have King
to E3 uh Rook the E4 with Chuck King the
F2 and now Queen to D2 with check and he
was in this position on a move 60 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
it's a mate on the next move regardless
of what you play with the King to G1 and
queen to G2 will be Checkmate so
incredible stuff uh like I said in the
four games that they played of Rapid
chess uh only black won the game like uh
four games zero wins for white uh and
then in the game where it mattered most
in Armageddon Artemis pulls off a win on
demand against um none other than than
Magnus Carlsen so he did get the black
pieces but it cost him a lot of time and
here it seems like it was he he probably
bid a bit too much uh you know giving
giving your opponent twice the time uh
and then allowing him to play such a
such a slow position like this uh I mean
e for C5 and then G3 of course that
Timmy will not go into something online
and allow magnets to get a playable end
game you know with basically spending a
couple of seconds on the clock uh he
really uh you know made his uh time work
for him so nicely done about 10 minutes
Magnus is out of the Winner's bracket he
now goes into the losers bracket and now
if he does really really well there he
will be able to you know climb out back
into the winner bracket and actually
still win the event uh if he plays well
if not you know we'll see what happens
so nicely done but
um I'm gonna check who he faces and next
I don't want to trick you guys uh let me
just check real quickly
uh okay so Artemis will face Fabiano
Corona who defeated um
and the Nakamura will face Wesley saw
and Hikaru defeated Vladimir velocity
they also went into Armageddon hikar was
able to get a draw with the black pieces
and Wesley just defeated um eleven
arunyan without even going to Armageddon
it was two and a half one and a half so
very very nicely done by Wesley uh so if
you have a game that you really enjoyed
I haven't seen all of them Do's hashtag
suggestion and I will go over it uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to baji and I would like to
thank Stephen Cornell ravishing reptiles
YouTube Eric Holtman and even settling
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day